>>> LEARNING A BIT MORE ABOUT
E TALKS THAT JUST ENDED
BETWEEN UKRAINE AND RUSSIA.
THE DISCUSSIONS LASTED OVER FIVE
HOURS.
BOTH SIDES HAVE AGREED TO MEET
AGAIN IN THE COMING DAYS.
WE'LL WAIT TO SEE HOW THAT PLAYS
OUT.
RIGHT NOW PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
LEADING A CALL WITH U.S. ALLIES
TO DISCUSS NEXT STEPS IN THIS
SHOWDOWN WITH RUSSIA OVER THE
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
EARLIER THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ADDING ANOTHER WAVE TO ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS AGAINST MOSCOW.
CUTTING RUSSIA'S CENTRAL BANK
OFF FROM U.S. DOLLAR
TRANSACTIONS.
RUSSIA'S PUTIN LASHED OUT AT THE
WEST TODAY CALLING IT AN EMPIRE
OF LIES.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE SUGGESTS
PUTIN IS ANGRY BECAUSE HIS
INVASION NOT GOING ACCORDING TO
PLAN.
>> I THINK WE ALL HAVE BEEN
AMAZED BUT ALSO STAND FIRMLY
WITH THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE, THE
UKRAINIAN MILITARY.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS BEEN A
PROFILE IN COURAGE.
REPORTING FROM KYIV.
AND I THINK IF WE LOOK AT
VIRTUALLY EVERY COMPONENT,
THINGS HAVE PLAYED OUT BETTER
THAN WE HOPE.
>> WITH US TO SHARE THEIR
REPORTING AND INSIGHTS, DANA
BASH, MARGARET TALEV AND
FRANCESCA CHAMBERS.
THE PRESIDENT ON THIS CALL WITH
EUROPEAN ALLIES.
YOU HEAR PEOPLE IMPRESSED WITH
THE COALITION, THE GLOBAL
REPUDIATION OF PUTIN RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE SOME NEW REPORTING THE
UKRAINIANS ARE HAPPY, BUT THEY
WANT MORE.
>> THEY DO.
AND WE'RE REPORTING NOW,
ZELENSKYY NOT ONLY WANTS A
NO-FLY ZONE BUT IS ASKING BIDEN,
THE WHITE HOUSE, AMERICA FOR A
NO-FLY ZONE.
GAVE A STATEMENT TWO AXIOS
THROUGH A SPOKESPERSON SAYING --
HE SAYS UKRAINE CAN BEAT THE
AGGRESSOR IF A WESTERN ALLIES DO
THEIR PART.
THE SANCTIONS ARE HELPING.
THEY ARE HEADING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
BUT THAT IF THE WEST DOES THIS,
MEANING THE NO-FLY ZONE, THE
UKRAINE WILL DEFEAT THE
AGGRESSOR WITH MUCH LESS BLOOD.
WE KNOW THAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
NOT READY TO TAKE THIS STEP.
THAT MOST OF CONGRESS IS NOT
READY TO TAKE THIS STEP.
THAT IT WOULD BE AN AGGRESSIVE
MOVE THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
ENGAGE THE U.S. MILITARY.
WHY IS ZELENSKYY TALKING ABOUT
IT ANYWAY?
BECAUSE HE HAS SEEN, NUMBER ONE,
WHAT THE RUSSIAN ASSAULT COULD
LOOK LIKE AND HOW MUCH WORSE IT
COULD GET.
AND HE'S SEEN WHAT PRECISE
MESSAGING IN THE MOMENT HAS DONE
TO SHIFT PUBLIC OPINION.
AND HE IS NOT GIVING UP ON THE
STATE OF PLAY.
HE IS NOT SAYING, OKAY, WELL,
THERE ARE THINGS THE WEST WON'T
DO.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT THE WEST MAY
DO MORE THAN THEY THOUGHT THEY
WOULD.
>> HE IS CENTRAL AT THE MOMENT
TO RALLYING GLOBAL OPINION
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS A BIG PART IN THAT.
YOU HAD A CONVERSATION WITH THE
U.S. AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED
NATIONS WHO WAS VERY WHOA ON
THAT IDEA OF A NO-FLY ZONE AND
BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
LET'S LISTEN TO THAT
CONVERSATION.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE CLEAR
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO PUT
BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO PUT AMERICAN
TROOPS IN DANGER.
SO THAT MEANS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
PUT AMERICAN TROOPS IN THE AIR
AS WELL.
BUT WE WILL WORK WITH THE
UKRAINIANS TO GIVE THEM THE
ABILITY TO DEFEND THEMSELVES.
>> THE QUESTION IS, WE'RE IN DAY
FIVE.
THE SITUATION HAS EVOLVED.
WILL IT EVOLVE MORE?
>> YEAH, THERE WERE -- WAS A
TIME, NOT THAT LONG AGO, LIKE
FIVE DAYS AGO, SIX DAYS AGO,
WHERE NOBODY THOUGHT THAT
GERMANY WOULD TAKE STEPS TO SAY
WE'RE GOING TO PUT A HOLD ON
NORD STREAM 2, THE PIPELINE.
NEVER MIND WHAT THE ALLIES HAVE
DONE COLLECTIVELY WITH THIS
S.W.I.F.T. BANKING SYSTEM, BUT
MUCH MORE IMPORTANTLY WITH THE
SANCTIONS IN PLACE OR GOING TO
BE IN PLACE ON THE RUSSIAN
CENTRAL BANK.
SO MANY THINGS NOBODY EXPECTED
TO HAPPEN BECAUSE PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY HAS BEEN SO OUT FRONT
AND BECAUSE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
ON THE GROUND AND THE RESOLVE OF
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
HAVING SAID THAT, YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU INTERVIEW SOMEBODY WHO IS
SORT OF AT THE TOP OF THE NEWS,
YOU DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW IF
THEY'LL ANSWER THE QUESTION.
I WAS KIND OF SHOCKED THAT THE
U.S. AMBASSADOR TO THE U.N. WAS
SO CLEAR IN HER ANSWER IN SAYING
THERE WILL NOT BE A NO-FLY ZONE
BECAUSE AMERICA DOES NOT WANT TO
HAVE U.S. TROOPS IN HARM'S WAY.
THERE WAS NO AMBIGUITY.
THE POINT IS A LOT OF TIMES WHEN
YOU TALK TO DIPLOMATS THEY DO
INTENTIONAL OR THEY CALL IT
STRATEGIC AMBIGUITY.
THERE WAS NONE THERE.
>> NONE THERE BECAUSE THAT'S THE
ADAMANT POSITION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE NATO ALLIES THAT
THERE'S A LINE.
THEY WANT TO HELP BUT LINES THEY
CAN'T CROSS.
WHAT IS STRIKING RIGHT NOW, YOU
MENTIONED PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY'S
ROLE IN THIS AND ALSO GIVE SOME
CREDIT, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
WANTED BIDEN TO BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE WITH SANCTIONS BUT
THEY'VE SEEN THIS COMING FOR
MONTHS AND THEY'VE WORKED ON
THIS DIPLOMACY.
THE SWISS TODAY, FOR YEARS,
NEUTRAL IN WORLD AFFAIRS.
STUDIOUSLY NEUTRAL ON PURPOSE
SAYING WE'RE FREEZING RUSSIAN
ASSETS.
THE UNITED STATES TAKING NEW
STEPS TODAY.
GERMANY SENDING, CRA ING UKRAIN
AND SENDING WEAPONS TO ASSIST
UKRAINE.
THE EUROPEAN UNION NOW WAITING
TO SEE IF IT CAN ADMIT UKRAINE
MAYBE ON A FASTER PATH THERE.
HUNGARY AS WELL.
THE GLOBAL COALITION HERE,
AGAIN, WE HAVE A LONG TO WAIT TO
SEE WHAT HAPPENS TO PUTIN, BUT
PUTIN HAS TO BE SURPRISED BY THE
IDEA THE REBUKE AND ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS ARE FROM JUST ABOUT
EVERY CORNER OF THE EARTH.
>> WHAT STRUCK ME IS HOW MANY
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS SAID
EXACTLY THAT YESTERDAY.
THAT PUTIN MAY HAVE
UNDERESTIMATED BOTH THE RESPONSE
WITHIN UKRAINE, BUT ALSO FROM
THE WEST AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND GERMANY AND
OTHER COUNTRIES, JOHN.
AND THE U.S. SAYS THEY WILL
ESCALATE AS PUTIN ESCALATES,
LAUNCHING THOSE NEW SANCTIONS,
TARGETING VLADIMIR PUTIN HIMSELF
BUT ALSO THE OLIGARCHS IN RUSSIA
SAYING, WE'RE GOING TO TARGET
YOUR YACHTS.
WE'RE GOING TO TARGET YOUR
CHILDREN AND FAM LEILIES.
YOUR KIDS AREN'T GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO COLLEGE HERE.
MAKING IT CLEAR THERE'S MORE
THEY CAN AND WILL DO.
>> IT'S A GIANT GLOBAL TEST FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
GIANT GLOBAL TEST FOR THE WORLD.
THIS CONFRONTATION WITH PUTIN.
AT A TIME THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS THE LARGEST
STAGE WE'LL HAVE THIS YEAR.
AND SO A MONTH AGO, THIS WAS A
VERY DIFFERENT SPEECH.
NOW UKRAINE HAS TO BE FRONT AND
CENTER.
AND THE PRESIDENT TRYING TO
CONVINCE A POLARIZED NATION,
IT'S TIME TO SUPPORT THE FLAG
AND THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF IN
THE CONFRONTATION WITH PUTIN.
>> IT'S TRUE.
BUT AGAIN, WHAT A DIFFERENCE
FIVE, SIX DAYS MAKES.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
CONFLICT, ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
IN TERMS OF THE POLITICS OF THIS
WAS WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE IN
AMERICA WOULD GET IT.
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME WHEN
INFLATION IS HIGH AND GAS PRICES
ARE HIGH AND THEY CAN'T --
>> AND THEY MAY GO HIGHER
BECAUSE OF THIS.
>> AND JUST IN TERMS OF THE
INITIAL ANECDOTAL RESPONSE, I'M
NOT LOOKING AT SPECIFIC POLL
NUMBERS ON THIS, BUT THE
ANECDOTAL RESPONSE, IT HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMING TO SEE HOW PEOPLE
ARE WATCHING WHAT IS HAPPENING
THERE BECAUSE IT REALLY BOILS
DOWN TO A FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
MITT ROMNEY PUT IT THIS WAY AND
I THINK THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE ARE
DIGESTING.
GOOD AND EVIL.
IT IS GOOD AND EVIL.
AND IT IS AS BLACK AND WHITE AS
THAT, THE WAY PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
AT IT, AND ALSO THE FACT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING, NO
U.S. BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND
THAT THE AMERICA WON'T ENGAGE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE MOST
PRECIOUS RESOURCE, AMERICA'S MEN
AND WOMEN, THAT THAT IS REALLY
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
>> THE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE
SEEMS SPLIT.
EVEN A WEEK AGO ABOUT WHETHER
THE U.S. IS SUPPOSED TO CARE,
WHETHER WE ARE TO CARE ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON.
I THINK THAT'S MOSTLY OVER.
THIS ARGUMENT LIKE YOU SHOULD
CARE MORE ABOUT THE BORDER SEEMS
TO BE MARGINALIZED TO THE RIGHT.
FOR BIDEN THE CHALLENGE
DOMESTICALLY IS THE REPUBLICANS
ARE UNIFIED AROUND THIS ARGUMENT
THAT IT WAS BIDEN'S WEAKNESS
RATHER THAN NATIONAL WEAKNESS
AND NATIONAL DIVISION THAT
PRECIPITATED THIS.
THAT'S A POLITICAL COMPLICATION
FOR THE PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
HUGE STAKES FOR TOMORROW, THE
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS.
IT'S GOING TO BE HUGELY
IMPORTANT MESSAGING TO AMERICANS
AND THE WORLD.
>> WE HEARD THAT ARGUMENT AGAIN
FROM THE FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP AT CPAC OVER THE WEEKEND
TALKING ABOUT THE BORDER.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, SPECI